Here is an example of an alternate starting point.
We could have started with the observation that, if I have a strain "foo"
contained within tags, contained within quotes, then the quotes are stripped
but the tags are still there.
And from that we could have devised the hypothesis that tags in
double quotes are not stripped.
If we will take a look into our code, now again in the buggy version,
in order for the HTML markup to appear in the output, tag must be false.
In order to have tag remain false, quote must be set.
And quote can only be set in this line, and then this would also have left us
with this precise condition to look at.
So although we start with a different hypothesis, we end in the same diagnosis,
and we also end up with the same fix. And here we go.
So from our hypothesis, we can deduce the tag must be false,
because otherwise the markup wouldn't be in the output.
Therefore, quote must be true, and therefore we have again our
erroneous condition, which sets quote.
Alternate starting hypothesis, same diagnosis, and same fix.